foreign
[Music]
October 2018 the anonymous street artist
known as Banksy published this video
online
in it he can be seen preparing a custom
frame for his painting girl with balloon
painting is about to be offered for
Sailors Sotheby's one of the world's
most exclusive auction houses
[Music]
the event was typical Art Auction Bank
sees lot was the last lot of the evening
the piece sold for over a million U.S
last chance at 850
000.
the gavel came down sold gone sold
setting for 860 000. as the hammer
struck the work started to fall through
the frame
[Applause]
[Music]
then as it did it shredded
and everybody witnessing her as it was
destroyed
I was like
ah street artist Banksy pulled off one
of the greatest pranks in the history of
the arc World it caused a huge stir I
mean nothing like that had ever happened
that stunt has already increased the
value of that painting up to seven
million dollars it plays on people's
fears and emotions and what true value
is where do we place value in society
who does art belong to
he created an art history moment and
wrote himself again into the history
books
[Music]
foreign
wasn't the first time that Banks he had
ambushed one of the August institutions
of the art world
15 years earlier in the winter of 2003 a
mysterious figure entered Cape Britain
one of the UK's most prestigious art
museums and placed a painting on the
wall
over the following 18 months fake
exhibits appeared in London's Natural
History Museum the Louvre in Paris and
the Museum of Modern Art in New York
all covertly installed by the same
Anonymous stranger
went through seven different galleries
putting seven different works of art up
in these galleries
the one in the Metropolitan Museum of
Art only lasted two hours which was
understandable because it was a painting
of a rather Posh looking lady she had a
gas mask on and that was spotted very
quickly but the one in the museum of art
that lasted for several days because it
was a painting of a Tesco can of soup
and it looked just like the Warhol cans
of soup and no one noticed it it was a
daring thing to do he did it he got away
with it and everyone suddenly knew his
name
but her name was all the public had
everything else remained a mystery who
was the secretive artist that had evaded
some of the world's tightest security to
hang his own work alongside that of
Monet Picasso and Warhol
was he just one person or was Banksy a
group of people
was he hiding his identity because he
was already famous someone known to the
public perhaps a musician or actor
[Music]
stunts themselves contained Clues
Banksy had launched an audacious game of
cat and mouse
at the Tate he had risked a rest to
bring his art to the public
they met his piece had been quickly
removed by curators who was sure that it
didn't belong in a gallery
and as Sotheby's Banksy had performed an
act of vandalism
and it was with vandalism
that it had all started
[Music]
graffiti has been used to start
revolutions stop Wars and generally as
the voice of the people who aren't
listened to
graffiti is one of the few tools you
have if you have almost nothing
and even if you don't come up with a
picture to cure World poverty you can
make someone smile when they're having a
piss
graffiti isn't an art form graffiti is a
reaction
an Impulse is like a spark
Dynamic explosive unpredictable
some people say graffiti ruined my life
and some people say you know graffiti
saved my life
a rush
um
it's an addiction
the rush I think is sort of a
consequence of it all you're scared and
your blood is pumping and your
adrenaline is pumping but really you're
doing it for the recognition and not the
rush
running around a city and getting your
name up in as many places as you
possibly can
the more risky the better
you want your name as big as possible
in lights you know so it's [__]
ridiculous but
graffiti is always the heartbeat of
society
that captures what's going on at that
time in that moment for every Banksy
that's on top and it's visible you've
got hundreds that may be underground and
invisible
[Music]
graffiti emerged in Philadelphia and
then New York in the late 60s and early
70s the city was in quote-unquote crisis
it was a city that didn't have much
revenue there was a lot of crime there
was a lot of drugs a lot of poverty
graffiti writing started in
neighborhoods like the Upper West Side
of Manhattan the Bronx Flatbush Avenue
Brooklyn and it was a movement started
by young kids that were writing their
names with their street numbers on the
walls around town to get
recognized in some way
sort of a game of tag you're actually
putting your name on a place and sort of
putting it more and more and more and
exposing yourself more than someone else
is coming and following you and doing
the same thing the game exploded when
kids decided to leave their streets and
go to the next street and the next
street and the next street the next
neighborhood in the neighborhood after
that
and it became hugely popular the taller
and wider people sprayed their names
then somebody came up with the bright
idea of putting a second color
around their name
and before you know it the stick letters
of small names on the back of bus seats
had turned into
seven foot high letters on the side of
subway trains
and so then it really exploded and
became an art movement
[Music]
thank you
painting or bombing New York Subway
system soon became the primary focus for
young Graffiti Writers obsessed with
having their name seen as widely as
possible
the nascent art movement developed its
own grammar rules and culture all based
around rendering letter forms
from the tag a signature scrolled
quickly with a spray can or marker pen
all the way up to the piece a
large-scale stylized depiction of the
artist's name
in 1983 the public was given its first
Glimpse inside the graffiti underground
with Tony Silva and Henry chalfant's
Landmark film style Wars for many Star
Wars depicted a strange criminal and
dangerous subculture but for others it
proved to be an inspiration
it was a new universe that was being
showcased
then it was like oh my God I gotta get a
piece of this
it became a guidebook for many people
you know where it was like this is how
it's supposed to be done
[Music]
people don't know what I look like until
now until they start going to the movies
are you gonna see my face big deal
traveling around the city on transport
and just like there's my tag there's my
tag there's my tag
it makes you feel like you own the city
it's like when you paint a train and you
see your train running
you know just the terminology I saw my
train running
isn't the train that somebody catches to
work this is my train with my name on it
and it's running
graffiti gives these young individual
some kind of ownership when they have
nothing
it's a matter of bombing knowing that I
can do it you know every time I get in
the train almost every day I see my name
I say yeah you know what I was there I
bombed it it's a matter it's for me it's
not for nobody else to see I don't care
I don't care about nobody else seeing it
or the fact if they can read it or not
it's for me and other Graffiti Writers
that we can read it all these other
people who don't write they're excluded
I don't care about them you know they
don't matter to me
but the Young Writers soon found that
the pursuit of their art meant facing
the full Wrath of the law
as complaints from the public increased
New York Civil Authorities announced a
war on graffiti
describe the artists as Outlaws and Link
the prevalence of tax to an upsurge in
other more serious forms of crime
I think it's the most disgusting
discussed in New York City
it's recently painted a couple of weeks
ago and they seem to know when you're
going to paint the station and at night
the station will be end up almost just
like this graffiti in New York has
become a deep-rooted social problem that
has bubbled Up From The Underground to
consume public buildings road signs bus
shelters and what's even more disturbing
people's homes it's just a general and
pervasive lack of consideration for
other people I think it's the bottom
line I think graffiti is what do you
want us is ah you know it's not a crime
but you know the government give us some
right to do we can make it look nice you
know what I'm saying well
for example say you lived in this
building yeah but you don't live in this
building you're coming into your house
you're drowning in this guy's house this
argument that graffiti is bad and the
graffiti should be treated as a blight
and that it should be treated as a as a
crime became more
the accepted point of view
the legal argument did actually hijack
the art discussion
it was an approach that has come to
define the relationship between Street
artists and Authority ever since
and would ultimately become a central
theme in banksy's work
battle lines were drawn and the artists
were permanently cast as belonging to
the criminal Underground
mayor Ed Koch signed a law a few weeks
ago that makes it illegal for a merchant
to sell spray paint or broad tip markers
to minors but Graffiti Writers for the
most part don't buy their paint they
steal it
ski one who writes in Upper Manhattan
says that while a friend distracts the
storekeeper he fills a bag you say some
kind of kind that they don't have but it
could be hard for them to look look for
it by the time they look for I'll have
um 250 cons 300 in your duffel bag yeah
could ruin your career your family your
relationships if you decide to be that
kind of a person that kind of an artist
you have to be well aware of those
consequences you want your work to be
seen by as many people as possible but
conversely you want to stay as Anonymous
as possible
graffiti was only one part of the
broader youth culture that emerged from
New York in the 70s and 80s
although it had developed independently
the art form became inseparably linked
to hip-hop a new type of music and dance
that like graffiti was an improvised DIY
scene born of the same desolate Urban
Landscapes of the Bronx Manhattan and
Brooklyn
Star Wars presented DJing wrapping
breakdancing and graffiti as expressions
of this same hip-hop subculture
when Tony and Henry created this film it
seemed like it was all together and it
was all this hip-hop package the young
kids that received their film around the
world decided that it was only one thing
they didn't just do the graffiti they
didn't just do the DJing or the dancing
they had to do it all
alongside style Wars Henry chalfant
published Subway art a book of the best
images from the subway system in
collaboration with photojournalist
Martha Cooper
the music book and film spread graffiti
beyond the perimeter of New York City to
walls trains and overpasses across the
planet
[Music]
I consider Star Wars and Subway art the
Holy Grail of graffiti right I went out
and I stole two cans of spray paint
which I learned became part of the sport
of graffiti and Iraqi paint and I went
to my high school that night I had like
two cans of white two cans of red and I
sat out there I was waiting for it to
get dark and I couldn't even made it was
like dusk jumped the fence went there
did this big surface it was terrible I
mean just the ugliest thing you ever saw
the next day I got the school's all
bummed out you know because it wasn't
like the photos I saw but I saw a huge
crowd around it and I was like that's so
cool and I was like that's cool
I'm off uh Cooper and Henry child from
completely changed the direction of my
life
I was a little kid I was down the King's
Road
I went into wh Smith's and I saw this
book called Subway art
and it was the first thing that I stole
and it became my Bible I was like oh my
God there's this place where people are
painting trains
and you don't know that they're trying
this and need to do this for some weird
reason hit pop and rap as being exported
from New York I was listening to
Grandmaster Flash and Sugar Hill Gang
and I was kind of into break dancing but
I couldn't break dance at all I wanted
to be part of this saying so
graffiti kind of like did it for me
[Music]
I come from a relatively small City in
Southern England
when I was about 10 years old a kid
called 3D was painting the streets hard
I think he'd been to New York and was
the first to bring spray painting back
to Bristol
I grew up seeing spray paint on the
streets way before I saw it in a
magazine or on a computer
[Music]
Bristol is a port it's a City built on
trade
most notoriously its trade was the the
slave trade the transatlantic slave
trade
old Bristol was destroyed in the Second
World War
and so the whole demographic of Bristol
changed because of working-class
community were moved out from the center
of town
and it took a long long time for Bristol
to be rebuilt certainly when I was
growing up in Bristol in the 70s and 80s
an awful lot of it was still bomber
sites and that coincided in the 70s with
the closure of the the city docks then
the sun Troopers to become a bit of a
wasteland
a very Multicultural City
in the last 30 or 40 years it's been an
incredibly kind of like creative
environment you know if you look at the
people that have come out there
you have Massive Attack tricky ports
head that have shaped like a new form of
music you have something like Banksy
that's gone on and become you know
famous worldwide
Bristol is big enough to have
interesting things going on but small
enough that people connect very quickly
and ideas spread quickly
Bristol had the opportunity to have a
really healthy scene I'm very focused
and healthy scene growing quite quickly
in the 80s
that scene it's our music and its
politics would come to shape Banks's
future career
in the mid 80s however he was still a
young Schoolboy trying to find out what
he might be good at
Banks's background is a regular middle
class Bristol boy I think I got an e in
art he never went to art school but
people who studied with him at the time
said he had something in his artwork
that they hadn't seen before
gotcha
Harmony where there is error may we
bring Truth where there is doubt may we
bring Faith and where there's despair
may we bring hope
[Applause]
you need to see what they're doing
the 1980s was a time in which Britain
was rocked by civil unrest and economic
turmoil as the conservative government
of Margaret Thatcher sought to
completely reshape the country
tearing up the old social contract
Thatcher launched a capitalist
Revolution that placed money on the
market at the center of national life
good evening Mrs Thatcher has said it
again her government intends to see its
economic policy through to a conclusion
Industries went out of business parts of
the UK particularly the North and the
Midlands were de-industrialized very
rapidly and became like ghost towns
there was this sort of almost overnight
desolation that descended on a lot of
the UK no prospects for young people
some of them turned to heroin it was a
bleak time
Bristol at the time was suffering from a
lot of Industries going unemployment
conflict there were riots it was like
much of Britain at the time quite an
unhappy City
it was still that old British mentality
of Friday night fight night and it
really was it was that kind of you know
went out drinking on a Friday he had a
fight you went home it was a good night
Bristol rebelled against the culture of
factorism
the idea of everything having a value
for example and it manifested itself in
the growth of the alternative culture in
Bristol and Bristol adopted Hip-Hop New
York hip-hop particularly as its
dominant subculture and it's from there
really that this anti-authority kind of
attitude seems to have come about not by
design by accident the arrival of
hip-hop made a spectacular impact on
Bristol's music and art scene
clubs in the largely black and Irish
Community of Saint Paul's began hosting
hip-hop nights and several of the city's
sound systems started to incorporate
emceeing and break Beats
the Wild Bunch sound system emerged as
the dominant force on the scene and its
Knights performing at the Dugout Club in
central Bristol quickly became the stuff
of Legend
the Wild Bunch was a group of DJs and
rappers out of the world Bunch grew
Massive Attack Nelly Hooper one of the
great producers of the late 20th century
were with sold to soul and Bjork it was
sort of like the the training ground for
people who would be defining cultural
figures of the British 90s
[Music]
they were definitely the coolest guys on
the scene at the time and a lot of
people wanted to imitate them
being able to put on a party in a house
charging 50p on the door hiring a reggae
sound system from some guys down the
road who had some really big speaker
boxes and having an illegal bar in the
corner and filling the house with a
couple of hundred people was relatively
straightforward
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
there was no coincidence that the
explosion of both
graffiti in Bristol at that time
and Hip-Hop culture and sound system
culture especially in Bristol
both seem to mushroom simultaneously
together
the twin art forms of music and graffiti
were personified by the single figure of
Robert Del Nair a founding member of the
Wild Bunch
also variously known as 3D delge or
simply D but spent some time in New York
during the early 80s and when he
returned to Bristol he brought graffiti
with him 3D was also icon in the UK's
first graffiti artist he was really a
Visionary he always had his eye on the
big picture
he would wander around and paint full
color
fully blown pieces of graffiti in very
very public spaces free hands with very
neat outlines very precisely well
thought out color schemes it was like
New York had arrived in Bristol
for us you know there's kids growing up
you know on Estates and everything else
is like suddenly you started seeing this
art form that belonged to us you know
for the first time ever like I'd never
been in a gallery I'd never gone to a
museum and then suddenly start seeing
this kind of visceral art form come out
of New York it was you know at that time
tied in with hip-hop as well and you
know I used to get the bus into town to
like travel around to see these pieces
3D started painting in 1983 and not long
afterwards the film wild style was shown
at the art center cinema in Bristol
how could you call people to hang out in
Windows and watch trains Riders man you
gotta rate you gotta do the actions man
you know you gotta go out there rack up
you gotta go out and paint and be called
an outlaw at the same time
myself and a group of friends sat and
watched this window on New York and all
the different aspects of the hip-hop
subculture
to then walk out the cinema and see all
this graffiti with the name 3D and the
Zed boys which was the crew that he was
painting with right there and then it
was immediate there were a number of
Crews that started that night and whilst
I was first shown at the Arts Center
cinema
this proliferation of budding graffiti
artists coincided with the retirement of
their spiritual leader Robert Del Nair
issued with a final warning by the
police Del Nair hung up his spray can to
concentrate on his music career he went
on to form Massive Attack one of the
most important British bands of the era
dalnayov was a Pioneer alongside him
there you had guys like Zed boys Ian Dar
Jaffa fade you add Felix Inky knit
Walker those for me were the originals
[Music]
thank you while Robert Del Nair had been
a lone Gunslinger roaming the streets of
Bristol stalked by the police the wave
of writers who came after him benefited
from the appearance of an unofficial
graffiti headquarters in the east of the
city
amid the social difficulties of the
1980s and Bleak prospects for most young
people
a local youth worker named John Nation
offered up the walls of his youth club
to any artist brave enough to travel to
the Badlands of Barton Hill
[Music]
I'd heard there was a graffiti Hall of
Fame somewhere in Barton Hill but my dad
was badly beating up there as a kid and
at his trousers stolen so I would always
put the fear of God into me about the
place of course it turned out to be the
most inspiring stretch of concrete in
Bristol and I made a pilgrimage there
every weekend
what it showed us was very powerful that
there was a choice between compromising
and following your own strange little
dreams
Barton Hill was an area which had a
terrible reputation
it struck fear into if you were not from
Barton Hill you didn't go to Barton Hill
why
working class
hostile to Outsiders from the area
very territorial
strong sense of community
but also
um Barton Hill had a reputation as being
a tough place and a lot that was to do
with
and all the generational ads that were
predominantly into football hooliganism
um a lot of them were deemed as being
into right wing National front
Barton Hill youth club provided a
meeting place for disaffected youth from
across Bristol kids who are getting into
a lot of trouble
and channeled their energies into a far
more creative way through what John
always referred to as aerosol art
two young guys had visited New York and
they approached me to paint the external
facial of bar in Hill youth club now at
that time the front of Barton Hill youth
club was adorned with
political statements National front
emblems Barnhill boot Boys Bristol City
service firm football hooligan crew that
kind of culture was what was being
displayed on Byron youth club at that
time so we decided this is something
that is fresh and the fact that these
two guys are born Hill locals and that
they want to do this was encouraging
that really was the the beginnings of
laying and sewing the foundations for
Barton Hill to grow a huge reputation in
the city
the one place in Bristol where you could
paint legally all day long on the walls
of the ball court and laterally on the
outside of the building it was Bliss it
was luxury we could sit around take our
time the other thing that Barton Hill
youth club had was that it backed onto
the railway tracks
painting safely and legally at a youth
center was one thing but it lacked the
glamor of New York Subway art the danger
the rush and crucial the ability to
achieve city-wide renown
the young Graffiti Writers at Barton
Hill used the club as a staging post for
bombing rates on trains buses and walls
across Bristol and before long their
names and styles became a familiar part
of the urban landscape you had artists
like Inky Felix choro era chaos and Sham
I started painting with a crew called
crime Inc and we followed the template
set down by 3D and as much as we would
sneak out after our parents were in bed
and go and paint pieces of graffiti
around the city
and the level of tagging that took over
in Barnhill encroached on the quality of
people's private and public property the
auto shop was getting knocked off in
Barnhill proper break-ins they managed
to find a way in through the back of the
premises and relieved them with hundreds
and hundreds of tins of pain many of the
houses that were on the house of the
state adjacent to born a new club their
front doors were tagged
their bins the local pub the wall was
absolutely caned with tags there was a
trail you could follow you would know
that there was a center where graffiti
was taking place and that this trail of
tags and throw-ups and dubs led to that
one Center Point which was Barton Hill
and this antagonizes a lot of the local
residents it got to a point where the
council and the police and British
transport police specifically were
starting to talk to one another and they
got to a point where they felt that
something had to be done
a city that can't control its vandals is
seen by many to be a city that's out of
control
in the summer of 1989 the British
transport police launched a series of
raids to arrest Bristol's most infamous
graffiti artists
the raids with the culmination of
operation Anderson a year-long
investigation into Barton Hill the
biggest anti-graffiti operation ever to
be undertaken in the UK a total of 72
people involved in the graffiti scene
were rounded up and charged with
criminal damage John nation was
interrogated and pressured to divulge
the real names behind the city's tax if
he refused to cooperate he would be
charged with conspiracy the most serious
offense that the police could allege
most of the artists were convicted but I
didn't divulge one person's identity to
the police and so they charged me with
conspiracy to organize and incite
individuals to commit criminal damage
I had a trust placed in Me by those
young people in the confidentiality and
the respect and the bond that I had with
those young people
would would be the determining Factor
[Music]
it might sound a little crazy but I
think John nation that shouty red-faced
little social worker who made it all
happen has had more impact on the shape
of British culture over the past 20
years than anyone else to come from the
city and I bet none of the cops who
arrested him can say that
so the consequence of operation Anderson
was that the majority of the writers
stopped which was what the authorities
of course wanted
the other consequence was that those
that continued went completely
underground and lived completely outside
the law so you had a smaller group of
very very hardcore writers who were
taking on the authorities and it was
into this
vacuum if you like
that
Banksy emerged
a generation younger than the first wave
of Bristol Graffiti Writers Banksy
showed up on the scene in the early 90s
where he fell in with one of the crews
that had remained active in the
aftermath of operation Anderson
Banksy first appeared working with the
dry breads crew which is the Loki in
Cato and Dems he was a snotty kid
hanging around
saying can I spray something as well
when it was largely ignored until he
just hung around so much that eventually
they relented and he started working
with dry breads or bad apples Crews were
essentially the same crew I think they
probably all came together around the
same time probably slightly dismayed
that people had actually been able to be
put off painting by what happened during
operation Anderson I'm sure it made a
young Banksy more determined to get his
work out there
they very quickly realized that there
was something a bit special about Banks
you know this little kid was pretty good
as a freehand artist at that time and
had some really interesting ideas a lot
of those ideas were around the placement
of the work sometimes the pieces which
dry breads or bad apples were putting up
were put up in places where they were
quite dangerous for them to paint so
quite public places and there was a
reluctance for them to go there because
they thought they'd be next until they
realized the next day when they were on
the bus that it was directly opposite
the bus stop and at eye level
with the the top deck of the bus and so
he thought out where the work was going
to be most visible
which is a theme which is really
important to banksy's word is where it
goes whether it's opposite a bus stop on
a busy Main Road in Bristol or whether
it's the Waldorf Hotel in Palestine the
placement of the work is absolutely
crucial to Bazaar I feel
when he first started he he was painting
letters you know he was
in all sense and purposes a graffiti
artist whether he was a great graffiti
artist that's debatable in my humble
opinion he's gone on to progress from
being
a half decent graph writer I would say
to a totally different conceptual artist
from the guys that he was with he was
off the radar at that point you know he
wasn't one of the known writers from
operation Anderson the police didn't
have his number they didn't know who he
was hence's anonymity was so important
to his work
banksy's early work suggested that he
was a different breed of graffiti artist
his pieces often included social
comments or vaguely political messages
highly unusual for an art form that was
mainly concerned with letter forms and
striking visuals
foreign
Banksy emerged during a time when
British culture was changing
following the arrival of house music
from Chicago the sound systems and three
parties of the 1980s had evolved into
large-scale illegal rapes fueled by a
new drug ecstasy
shut out of graffiti by operation
Anderson many of Bristol's underground
artists drifted into the Rave scene
where they continued to disregard
society's established rules
State response to Rave would be one
event among several that directly
politicized Banksy
by the early 90s the conservative
government which had always been
repressive towards minority groups and
those outside of the mainstream were
struggling to maintain its Authority
the poll tax a new system of Taxation
felt by many to be an attack on the poor
provoked Fierce writing in London pit
the police against the people and led to
the downfall of Margaret Thatcher
right
after John Major replaced Thatcher as
prime minister his government launched a
campaign against groups that it
considered to be socially disruptive
in 1994 the deeply unpopular criminal
justice and public order act paved the
way for a Crackdown on Raves
it gave the police sweeping powers to
stop and search evict squatters and to
take action against a gathering of as
few as five people listening to what it
termed repetitive Beats
hulo also discriminated against both
Gypsies and travelers an attenuate
community that traversed the British
Countryside in Caravans and was
associated with anarchism
environmentalism libertarianism and
other radical ideas
[Music]
I got politicized during the poll tax
riots the criminal justice Act and the
heartcliffe riots that was Bristol's
Rodney King
I can also remember my old man taking me
down to see the Lloyd's Bank what was
left of it after the 1980 Saint Paul's
riots in Bristol
it's mad to see how the whole thing of
having to do what you're told can be
taken back and how few people it takes
to grab it back
Sy was close to the traveler Community
who were a large presence in the
southwest of England
the Glastonbury Festival Britain's
annual summer celebration of Music peace
love and alternative living took place
not far from Bristol and travelers were
a fixture at the site
in 1998 he painted this piece inspired
by hip-hop and rave on the side of a
trailer at the Glastonbury Festival
The Unofficial logo of Rave appears in
many of his later stencils
by the close of the 90s Banksy pictured
here during a trip to visit the
left-wing zapatista rebels in Mexico had
become an artist for whom message was as
important as image
certainly in the early days you know it
was that very kind of simplistic like
left-wing attitude of emotions of
Travelers which you know I'm a lifelong
labor supporter but you know I can't
stand that traveling scene never could
never will yeah but you know I can see
where bits of that came through to him
in his mentality in the way he thought
he was reflecting the anti-captism the
anti-authority the anti-war feelings
which were prevalent among the Bristol
underground at the time and a genuine
belief that the world could be changed
to be a better and fairer place
at the same time Banksy was evolving
stylistically
stenciling a technique that had notably
been favored by Robert Del Nair became
an increasingly important part of his
work
[Music]
something that if you were doing
freehand would take you hours and if
you're using a stencil
would take you less than five minutes
and you probably won't get caught doing
it
you have an idea you have an image you
print it out you then project that image
onto a piece of card in your studio you
cut it out into like a three layer
stencil
you then walk up to a wall and you stick
the first layer of the stencil on the
wall which isn't illegal
and you stand there and you wait for No
One to come
take it down give it to you mate let's
take the next layer up
which again isn't legal so it's pretty
hard to get caught painting stencils
everyone can understand them they're not
this dense tagging you see them you
click immediately
it's the time that you spend in your
studio thinking of the idea
and doing the preparation
[Music]
is why I think
it's slightly better than graffiti
[Music]
I think stencils initially were met with
quite a lot of division they weren't
taken very seriously
a graffiti artist would never be caught
dead doing that that's the main
differences we would never do that [__]
traditional graffiti artists have a lot
of rules that they like to stick to and
good luck to them but I didn't become a
graffiti artist so I could have other
people tell me what to do
if you're gonna do graffiti you've got
to steal your spray paint and you've got
to paint trains and you've got to tag
stuff
you know if you want to sit there in
Your stagnating Graffiti it has to be
like this world then poor you
because everything evolves and moves on
[Music]
foreign
that Evolution dates back to the very
early days in New York
at the time that the hardcore Graffiti
Writers were bombing trains work
appeared on the streets and in the
subway stations that shadowed the
underground culture of tags and pieces
but was recognizably different
together with his friend Al Diaz a young
artist named Jean-Michel Basquiat toured
Lower Manhattan writing the attack Samo
an abbreviation of same old [__]
accompanied by thought-provoking slogans
and epigrams another Young artist Keith
Herring was tracking the same old pieces
while developing his own form of illegal
public art
drawing chalk outlines of figures and
characters on vacant advertising boards
in the New York subway and attaching
mock headlines to lampposts around
Manhattan
Basquiat and Keith Herring were really
the beginning of
street art modern street art as we
understand it in that it was taking the
tools and the philosophy and the kind of
ethos behind graffiti but stepping to
one side with it statements that have
more to do with newspaper headlines or
the kind of posts you'd see outside of
church say looking at the ideas of
public space and how one could create
art that would be seen by a mass
audience rather than elitist audience
and that's kind of the key difference
banksy's well aware of the history of
the art form and those kind of key
players at Key moments
and for Banksy there was no influence
more important than the French stencil
artist Black lorat
black who had first encountered graffiti
during a trip to New York adapted the
idea of street art to the European
tradition of stenciling political
statements on walls
his project to bring socially conscious
art to the public began in 1981. when
stencils of rats started to appear in
the streets of Paris
black lorat's signature wasn't black
lorat it was the rat
[Music]
rats like everywhere like running around
and you see multiple Rats on the walls
it was also painting homeless people on
walls and so he basically was an artist
that had a message his message was look
at these things that are wrong in the
city look at the homeless population
there's something wrong that there's so
many homeless people
they're invisible to us I'm going to
make them more visible by painting them
on the walls right
high on concept low on technology
whereas the graffiti artist may be the
other way around you know where it's
definitely about say this technical
skill with the spray can that kind of
thing these you know intricate letters
which is great and fantastic but you
know who are you speaking to and
ultimately what is the goal at the end
but if the goal at the end is I really
want to say change the world like I want
to deal with these bigger headier
Concepts and that's where uh Banksy
change the game
he's taken the best of all these
different worlds the graffiti world and
how he operates in the street the
stencil world and what he creates as an
image and sort of this social activist
point of view the three different let's
say personality types packaged into one
person you have a really high profile
art Terrorist on your hands right
in the mid 90s a British television
program Shadow People captured a young
Banksy at work
the program provides a fascinating
insight into how Banksy was painting
around Bristol in the wake of operation
Anderson and how he viewed himself as an
artist
the footage also showed that by 1995
stenciling rather than freehand painting
had become Central to his art
[Music]
yeah I've decided that I don't ever want
to do a gallery show off the proper
gallery show and I don't think um
you know salty came to me with a lot of
money I turned the [__] off you know and
I don't I don't feel the need
to go to a gallery to make my art for a
legitimate
and that if I go to the pub and somebody
says that they like what I've just done
and I might get a beer or I might
meet a girl that likes what I do
and that's enough
[Music]
by the close of the 90s Banksy had
become an important figure on the
Bristol art scene together with the
graffiti artist Inky he organized walls
on fire a landmark event supported by
the city in which street artists legally
painted over 400 meters of hoardings in
Bristol Harbor while sound systems
pumped out hip-hop
a few months later Banksy painted the
mild mild West his first large-scale
mural on the side of an abandoned
building in the stokescroft area the
mural soon became an iconic Monument to
Bristol's local culture I've always seen
it as being a welcome to Bristol sign
it's actually a reference to a
particular party which was broken up by
the police and its banksy's protest if
you like against the police taking on
the Rave scene
we might be peace loving we might just
be after a good time we might be just
trying to do our own things but don't
push us too far it kind of distilled his
aesthetic and though it was painted
freehand Banksy stenciled his name along
the bottom if you take wolves on fire as
a comparison he was still painting
traditional New York graffiti up to that
point the mild Mile West made it very
clear where he was going from there
Banks's direction of travel was away
from graffiti and towards a career as a
new type of contemporary artist in 2000
he graduated from the streets with a
small Exhibition at the seven Shed
Restaurant in Bristol
show with its canvases painted by an
Infamous local Vandal attracted the
attention of both public and media alike
yeah were the two rats then the rat up
there with the propeller what do you
think of it I think it's both strange
can I just introduce you to the man who
actually sprayed that thing would you
call him a vandal well I suppose you are
being a fan of really
graffiti has taken Banksy to cities
across Britain as the original Street
Outlaw but recently he's moved to London
started accepting commissions and is now
holding a conventional exhibition well
I'm kind of old-fashioned and I like to
eat you know so it's always good to earn
money and also I'm trying to make
canvases work better than graffitian
workers or she can take time on it
because he doesn't always come out the
way you like it because you're rushing
you're panicking or whatever every
artist has to develop and it's time for
Banksy to face new challenges that show
really caught people's imagination
people who didn't know his work went
there and thought wow this Aunt talks to
me it's radical it's clever it's witty
it's got a political point it's well
executed I know several people who
bought pieces there who said it was the
first time they'd ever bought any art
though exhibiting in Galleries and
working on commission Banksy remained
active as the legal artist
his street work no longer belonged to
the graffiti scene but neither was he
associated with the Contemporary Art
World in
instead Banksy was part of a new group
of post-graffiti artists who like
Basquiat Keith Herring and blechlerat
before them were experimenting with new
forms of an authorized Urban art
I thought graffiti was going to change
the art World Shake everything up and it
didn't do that
it just stayed relatively underground
you know the most success that graffiti
had was working with Brands you know it
didn't really make it into art galleries
it wasn't picked up by collectors
and as I was becoming more and more
disillusioned with graffiti this weird
thing called street art started to
happen
Graffiti Writers reinvented themselves
and he had people like costume revs who
started putting wheat paste up
everywhere with all kinds of messaging
and then you have the emergence of
people like Shepard Ferry who also saw
the potential of just like putting
posters like Rock Club announcements or
Punk announcements
[Music]
all of a sudden these little rats
started appearing and more people were
doing stickers that weren't
based around a skateboard brand
there was Shepherd fairy there was bash
there was fowl Banksy
Ross geminos
people using an opportunity in the
street and turning it into their
advantage
you know turning bollards into like
missiles and you know and it sounds like
corny and [__] but it was just something
different
there was a bunch of people around the
world that were doing something that
wasn't graffiti and at the time it
didn't have a name
[Music]
the nascent street art movement found a
home in shoreditch a rundown District in
London's East End where a new
underground was thriving
tomorrow
it was a mixed place where immigrants
people without much money all could mix
this whole new Street Scene began to
move in
artists went there of all types because
the rent was cheap
Banksy now living in London was a
fixture at the Dragon
small bar tucked away in a side street
near the old Street roundabout that had
become the informal headquarters of the
street art community
Dragon Ball was this unique
weird place that was run by a guy called
Justin pigger
who was an ex-junkie
but ins are and it was modeled on like a
Lower East Side kind of divey
skateboardy graffiti bar
and at the back of the bar they had this
car park
and we used to put parties on there
and because it was just that little bit
out of like the Beaten Track
would keep it open all night you know we
had a license to 11 o'clock and we keep
it over serving booze until three
o'clock in the morning and it just
became this like weird loyal Zone
it was just like a you know a
three-wheeling kind of Madness where you
know yeah everybody knew each other you
had artists coming in you had fail
coming into town bass
Invader Shepard like all these guys
congregated there and it was an
epicenter really of the beginning of the
scene
at that time shortage and Tower hamlets
and Hackney they were the poorest
boroughs in London
so you could do stuff in the street and
it wouldn't get cleaned off
and then it was like the whole place
became a wall of fame
[Music]
me and Banksy we painted all the posters
that used to go on shortage Bridge
upstairs in the dragon bar
[Music]
you know we'd go there we'd cut stencils
make posters
and then two o'clock in the morning when
we were pissed enough go out and jump
over Railway Bridges and paint stuff
thank you
armies of rats monkeys and other images
started to appear all over London a new
type of visual language that became part
of the fabric of the East End and which
locals came to associate with a single
mysterious name
it's about underground culture the
things that come up from the sewers like
most people I have a fantasy that all
the little powerless losers will gang up
together that all the Vermin will get
some good equipment and then the
underground will go overground and tear
this city apart
they'll be like oh yeah I'm going to go
out and paint some wraps so yeah we'll
come look out and
help your pain and yeah
I was just like yeah get some cans of
beer from the [__] from the Kebab
shop
and off on your bikes and cycle around
and it was just fun it was like really
like innocent and naive and just fun we
were literally just having a laugh
I don't think any maybe Banksy did maybe
he had more of a plan than the rest of
us but I don't think any of us thought
really had like we were just doing it
for fun
it was a really interesting fun time
that was nothing to do with Finance or
hammered money things cost like these
guys were just doing it for shits and
giggles it was like no one at the time
thought they were ever going to make any
money out of it they just had something
to say
it reminded me of graffiti we were
running around stenciling climbing over
Bridges
it wasn't about putting your names up
there it was about putting your imagery
up there
[Music]
there's an interesting mix of traveler
Anarchist Punk politics
combined with end of the pier uh misses
English Seaside humor
the jokes are easy to get but the
imagery is accessible and digestible
very palatable to the everyday person to
walk by and say oh
okay
because you don't choose your audience
if you're putting work on the street the
work is talking to people of all classes
or Creeds or colors or religions or ages
it didn't make people feel stupid
they're trouble with a lot of Art
galleries museums I think it intimidates
people and this was something that was
easy to get and people could understand
and felt that it belonged to them this
is Arts were not made to feel stupid for
the first time I can like art
is that juxtaposition of iconic imagery
that many times we took for granted
you put that over here you're going to
say this about it and then it's like
okay now we almost have like this
tension filled conversation that you
just can't walk by now you got to stop
now you gotta you know think about it
and you didn't have to pay for it
[Music]
there are jokes always like the signs
saying designated graffiti area or
designated Riot area it makes you laugh
and it makes you think about the issue
he's raised
there's a lot of imagery related to
innocence there's often children there's
often nature
animals things that we associate with
people or things that need to be cared
for Banksy has a pretty wide repertoire
of recurring figures in his work the
mice
they're typically engaged in some weird
hijinks
also frequently appear they're often
shown to be kind of smarter
more interesting than humans that they
will probably take over once we've
finished screwing up the whole world and
destroying it
the kids I think show the precociousness
that exists the joy that exists the sort
of naivete the fun that can still exist
in the world and how children sometimes
are oblivious or even smarter than the
adults
they're a very important piece of his
work and really communicate really
strong messages about where we are as a
society
then policemen often appear too they're
shown as figures of authority who should
be questioned but they're also shown
sympathetically people who are in roles
of authority that sometimes they feel a
conflict with
thinking also of the two policemen
kissing and that being something to
think about policemen in a different way
maybe than we sometimes do
He is wanting to uphold the beauty and
power and selfhood of the everyday
person
in contrast to institutional systems
that are kind of weighing things down
and controlling things
[Music]
the street art scene arrived at a time
when the established Contemporary Art
world had to some extent lost its way
British art and culture had thrived
during the 90s the conservative
government of the poll tax and the
criminal justice act had been swept away
by the wave of optimism that carried
Tony Blair into office and the phrase
cool Britannia was coined to capture the
sense of pride in British culture music
film and fashion
it was all happening in Britain there
was a new spirit a new confidence and
Youthful energy
[Music]
Britain was swinging again
almost like a replay of the 60s
go-getting like we're going to take over
the world you know
the Contemporary Art scene was dominated
by the so-called young British artists
or ybas a loose grouping of insurgent
artists led by Damien Hurst and
celebrated as daring and rebellious eye
comiclasts
but by the early 2000s cool Britannia
had burned itself out and the yba's
luster had faded big money had moved in
and for many it was hard to escape the
feeling that normal service had been
resumed
one million six the art world is the
biggest joke going it's a redstone for
the overprivileged the pretentious and
the weak the modern art is a disgrace
never had so many people use so much
stuff and taken so long to say so little
still the plus side is it's probably the
easiest business in the world to walk
into with no talent and make a few bucks
the young British artists have become
the establishment Hearst started off as
a revolutionary he was now the
establishment
Damien Sarah nanga Saul showed together
in a seminal show in 1988 called Freeze
16 years later they're exhibiting
together but it taped Britain rather
than in a warehouse
we're not we're no longer at ybas we're
oaps
Autumn becomes glamorous
become fashionable Charles arches
Gallery made it into an important source
of money for artists and something had
to crack in this because this is not
what art is supposed to be all about and
what came out from it was street art
straight art was always really good at
being the little cheeky chappie doing
that little thing behind your back oh
it's kind of funny oh he's having a
problem of the government
your older brother was into Damien Hurst
and
your younger brother who's necking pills
and going raving is in a Banksy
the art would completely ignore it
because it's a populist art form and I
think the art World hate that populism
isn't a bad thing it doesn't mean
something's crass and [__] sometimes it
just means that people like it
this was like a movement that became
powerful through the people not through
museums and Galleries and curators this
was driven by a general love of the art
form by the general population
I'm frustrated by many things but trying
to get accepted by the art world isn't
one of them
this seems difficult for people to
understand
you do not paint graffiti in the vain
home that one day some big fat toriel
discover you and put your pictures on
his wall
if you draw on walls in public then you
are already operating on a higher level
but whereas the ybas had benefited from
Studios galleries grants and patrons
London Street artists had few resources
beyond the beer stain floor of the
Dragon bar for Banksy a friendship that
he had formed with photographer and
fellow bristolian Steve lazaridas soon
became key to promoting his art
Steve lazarides was vital to
Banks his career for a time what they
did was show that you didn't have to
have a gallery be attached to a gallery
to be a well-known successful artist
they could make their own Gallery they
could attract people to it through
various means that lazaridis was
absolutely King at what love readers did
with Banksy was to establish a new way
of getting art to the public
[Music]
the do-it-yourself ethos of the graffiti
and free party scenes carried over to
the project of building a system for the
sale and exhibition of street art
one of the first installments came in
the winter of 2002 with Santa's ghetto
an exhibition of work by Banksy and
benign that went on to become an annual
event we've been painting stuff on the
streets and
I think some of us had websites so we
were aware of an interest in people that
wanted to consume or buy
what we were doing but we didn't really
have anything for sale or way of selling
it so we did a science ghetto party
and yeah the first one was upstairs at
Dragon Ball
friend of ours and Marcus was the drunk
horrible stinky Santa in the corner
and yeah we sold everything for like 50
Quid or something
it was completely an Arctic I was
walking through Shore dates from the
offices to the um to the dragon bar with
like handfuls of Banksy prints that
would never be worth you know millions
of pounds so just taking them up there
and then yeah I kind of ran it and sold
it and it was completely mental
take over a building and don't turn it
into an art gallery you know just
anti-art Gallery antique establishment
you know and yeah go and wrap that punk
kind of like ethic
we were selling the multiple canvases so
at the time it cost 250 quid so a girl
in bloom was 250 pound for a canvas and
he painted them all
um in in the upstairs of where we were
so we had like 25 canvases laid out as
he was spraying them like I was
numbering them then he'd sign them and
then we'd take them downstairs and sell
them as we were going out so and that
was the whole idea really at the in
those early days was to make again like
affordable art for people
public interest in the movement was
soaring
work that in earlier times might have
been seen only by a handful of people
who pass it on the street could now be
preserved and shared online greatly
enhancing the profile of the artist
Banksy was clearly emerging as the most
prominent of the street artists at a
time when youth culture was turning its
face against governments on both sides
of the Atlantic and protesting the war
on terror and invasion of Iraq banksy's
anti-war anti-authority Angie prop
chimed with a popular mood
the war was very important to banksy's
development the no war the wrong War
Arts very much came from that period it
was a perception that new labor and Tony
Blair had let down the generation the
post-stater generation the same people
running society and Banksy and his
generation I think very much came out of
that there's a real distrust
I think you could see a lot of the
spirit of that 80s and 90s only growing
scene in a lot of his earlier political
work definitely and
that's for me what struck an accord with
the vast majority of the British public
who
tapped into the Banksy phenomena was
that spirit
he was able to articulate a lot of
things that you know people were
thinking but not having to say
wherewithal or the tools or the
Ingenuity to say you know this is what
it is
[Music]
in the summer of 2003 Banksy staged his
breakthrough exhibition Turf War
a collection of his street work
sculpture and vandalized live animals
some of which were painted in homage to
Graffiti folklore
cattle pigs and sheep are the latest raw
material for this man he calls himself
Banksy but that's not his real name he's
a graffiti artist and he believes that
anonymity is essential oh this guy's
because
um you know you can't uh you can't
really be a graffiti writer and then
it's called public time
it's like the two things uh you can't
quite go together
the event caused a sensation in London
with celebrities jostling to get in and
the media crowning Banksy the UK's most
fated underground artist
I wish I was hilarious it was like in
this huge squat up on Kingston Road and
the thing with banks is like even in
those early shows like where wherever he
did it and whatever period there were
always like supremely well attended it's
like just chaotic
there were queues outside models trying
to get in everyone trying to get in
and the rspca was tipped off that he was
being cruel to animals Banksy fears not
the critics but the inspector from the
rspca who's come to see if the animals
are being maltreated the farmer from
Somerset who owns the animals there's no
qualms but will the Animal Welfare man
agree the artist and the farmer have
assured me that they they've been
painted using animal identification
sprays which is non-toxic washes off
very easily so there's going to be no
harm done even if the animal licks
itself it's hard to make an entertaining
picture at the best of the time but at
least if you have something that kind of
wanders around and licks its nose
and urinates in front of you then it's
gonna it's gonna make the picture a bit
more interesting right despite having a
proper exhibition like this Banksy
insists he's still a graffiti artist
now graffiti is trying to climb into the
pan to spray the cow I'm trying to
explain to me it wasn't actually spray
paint on it it was it was animal diet
and then we had a animal rights
protester that came up and chained
herself to the scaffolding what she
didn't know all we had to do was kind of
undo the thing and slide our handcuffs
off but we left it there all day because
we thought it was a good look you know
we give her some food and some drink and
everything else and actually quite
politely at the end of the day kind of
packed up and went off
that was the one really that kind of
kicked off that kind of Big Show
mentality with like multiple things
going on
you know he had pigs who had sheep you
had cows you had two Vans up on top of
each other in a squat in the middle of
nowhere
it was only on for three days and
thousands of people turned up
this was the exhibition that established
him that meant that street art
was a phenomenon that had to be
recognized
he just had like this great vision to be
able to put on shows that weren't in
white walled spaces and to show people
that art could be viewed in a different
way and I think yes on that level I
think he was one of the forerunners to
do those kind of shows well at that
point in time wasn't even a movement it
was just you know it was just us running
around doing stuff
that was about to change with the
founding of pitchers on walls another
step in the reimagining of the art
economy a print house started by the
artist Jamie Hewlett Banksy and Steve
lazaridas with benign as the printer
Peaches on walls aim to bring together
Street artists from around the world and
make their work accessible to the
General Public
I went to pick Banksy up from Bristol I
acted he diverted me and we went to some
print place to pick up some prints so it
was a stack of the rude copper print and
I'm like so but what what are you gonna
do with him so I'm taking them to the
anarchist book fair and I'm going to
sell them for a Fiverr each then I was
just like well you're an idiot I'll buy
them I'm selling for 20 quid come on
let's see you know we can do better with
it than that and then you know he kind
of came up with the concept of pictures
on walls and again the whole ethos for
pitched on Wars was to make cheap
affordable art for the masses
I was always into the American screen
print system
whereby you'd have like artists like
Frank Kozak and cope
that would design gig posters for beauty
boys Nirvana
and every time the Beastie Boys did a
gig as they taught Across America there
would be a poster that you could buy for
30 quid
people were producing these really
affordable [__] call what I consider
to be cool piece of art by people that I
consider to be artists and you could buy
them really really cheap
and the only screen prints available
that you could get in England were like
for higher
and I wanted to try to do something that
was more based on the American gig
poster system and that was kind of the
idea behind pigeon walls when we started
it
and again in that kind of not knowing
what we were doing so you know we were
making print runs like 600 and 750 not
knowing that that wasn't really
considered a limited edition but you
know still went on and did it and then
started sucking in other artists to work
on it as well like Invader mode two so
then like everyone got involved in
suddenly it was like a focal point for
the movement about like picking people
to come and do print
you know no one's earning money back
then so you know you do a premium
pictures and walls you could earn like
you know six grand
you know which is a lot of money back
then
so I saw it as a way whereby
I could make these artists money and do
something that I thought was kind of
like quite important and showcase their
work
and the first print I did was a print by
an artist from Norway called doc
and it was a labrador [__] R2D2
really high brow stuff we were doing
moment
although simple in concept Banksy and
lazarida's activities were at the time
revolutionary
street art movement had managed to
bypass all the established structures
for producing exhibiting and selling
works of art and as laser readers
established himself as an art dealer
banksy's became increasingly valuable
properties
Banks is pretty good at kind of like
working people and getting into
different crowds and different scenes
you know jugal or some Jude Law was
coming down and giving us 10 grand for
painting
I was like drug dealers at that point
they were great people to buy heart
there was loads of cash I thought this
art movement was cool they you know they
understood it a lot more than the ybas
it was affordable and we were the cheeky
little [__] running around London and
people want to buy into that
we had no idea what we've been doing
pricing wise I just made it up as we
went along so my theory was if someone
had 500 quid
they've probably got 1500 so if we did
something at 500 quid and it sold out
next time around it would be 1500 and
then it was like well it's about 15 then
they might have five and it just jumped
like that and it you know and in the end
when it started to get to like tens of
thousands of pounds I could only do it
if I didn't say the full amount that the
piece cost it's like oh Christ have I
tell them there's 15 grand I'm just
going to burst out laughing and it's
like yeah mate it's 15.
we made it quite difficult for people to
buy pieces and like I said it was like I
had no plan I never wanted to open a
gallery it was just we just made it up
[Music]
foreign
that winter Banksy entered tape Britain
placed a painting on the wall and walked
into the history books
with the incursions in museums and
Galleries and other stunts that followed
Banksy pioneered a new type of illegal
performance art and in doing so he began
to transcend the street art scene
what really set him up was his
interventions in galleries in New York
London and Paris
that suddenly gave him the publicity
that was needed
to make him into an artist that everyone
knew who he was
careful planning
those were almost like a bank job you
know you'd sit and plan it out work out
how it was going to work if you think
that he took a box that was this size
with a freeze-dried rat in it
drilled into the wall in the middle of
the day in the Natural History Museum
during a half term and put this piece up
on the wall
[Music]
it's not just Banksy there is a team
although it's Banksy who's got to face
up to putting the picture on the wall
and possibly getting arrested
[Music]
one of the gallery invasions some of his
team
stays the sort of gay Tiff an argument
going on so that there was a disturbance
which allowed Banksy to go and put a
picture on the wall
once they set things in motion
you know I was always maybe you know
like 20 30 50 feet away kind of
photograph and everything thinking like
there's nothing I can do to tip them off
or stop it if like they're about to get
caught
[Music]
did folks attention on somebody who was
Anonymous and so you've got a dilemma
there immediately it also confirmed his
relationship with the art world as being
an outsider as someone who was not
didn't have access
to galleries it owed a lot to Graffiti
going into at Disneyland and handcuffing
Guantanamo prisoner to railings and
getting out without getting caught the
stakes are much higher and the audience
is much bigger
um but the thinking is is largely the
same I think I think Banksy was becoming
a different kind of an artist he became
this sort of hybrid street artist
social activist ad hacker graffiti guy
all into one
in 2005 Banksy embarked on his most
eye-catching project yet accompanied by
benign he traveled to the Middle East to
paint the West Bank barrier
a controversial wall erected by the
Israeli government the barriers
separated the Palestinian territories
from Israel and was felt by many to be a
supreme Injustice aimed at annexing
Palestinian land and subjugating the
population
in traveling to Palestine a territory
under military occupation Banksy
combined his Flair for highly planned
audacious and risky stunts with his use
of striking imagery and sense of social
mission
the collection of paintings that
resulted were met with International
Acclaim we wanted to go to Brazil
because none of us have been to Brazil
and the girls were really fair in Brazil
and all of their girlfriends put their
foot down and said no you're not going
to go to Brazil
there was three of us at the time
now you're not going to go to Brazil
that's ridiculous
so fundamentally the biggest rule in the
world
and it seemed like something that was
continually in the Press always a
problem
the most religious
crazy insane hot spots
and the biggest rule in the world so as
a bunch of people that likes painting
walls
perfect destination
I think we probably spent two weeks
there and we painted a load of stuff and
none of it was particularly political
which is why we got away with what we
got away with
gun paint the soldiers have come up they
Point guns at us let's ask us questions
we'd be like oh we're idiots artists
from London
and they'd be like okay go now go now
and be like yeah can we just quickly
finish we're gonna be finished in like
two minutes and then okay Finish if you
we see you again we get you arrested and
then we drive like 20 miles down the
road or something
the challenges were getting stuff into
the country
and getting stuff out of the country
getting the photographs and the memory
sticks and the laptops out of the
country getting ladders getting a car
throwing somewhere to stay
we stay in this hotel and no one had
stayed there for like three years
I think we did quite a few workshops
with like local kids in Palestine so we
use that as a bit of an excuse to like
get art equipment in
there's not a Montana shop in Palestine
she can't just get your mum's credit
card and Order load of [__] online and
it turns up the next day
this idea of upping the stakes and
challenging yourself to go one step
further his produce some of his best
work
the work that Banksy created in
Palestine in 2005 was very powerful the
ones that I remember are as if the wall
the barrier between Palestine and Israel
were cracked open you know and on and
you could see through it but you see
Paradise you see blue skies you see
nature you see children
and that really was such a stark
difference from the Palestinian plight
and from what's Happening there looked
nothing like what he painted
certain people were becoming a lot more
kind of like
understanding the way that the pr
machine works so it wasn't until we came
back that those images became political
and there was the message behind what we
were doing
if banks you painted a big wall in
London
then maybe the Arts editor in the
guardian would write something about it
on one of the back pages
but this was one of the first times when
it actually kind of blew up
I think the first trip to Palestine
elevated him to being a more serious
artist than perhaps anyone had taken him
for because don't forget this was only
two years after he'd been into galleries
putting art on walls and Harry was
saying yes I can joke around like this
but I'm also God I've got serious points
I want to make
the plight of the Palestinians would
become a recurring theme in banksy's
life and work and in 2007 he held the
annual Santa's ghetto in Bethlehem
the underlying message is that people
should come and see the harsh daily
reality for themselves and some
Palestinians are impressed actually I
like the towers the towers
I like them because I see them
everywhere where I travel in the West
Bank but it's the first time that I see
them like in a colorful way or something
like I wish that the Israeli Army is
influenced by this eight years later
Banksy journeyed to Gaza where he made a
two-minute film that Drew attention to
the devastation caused by recent Israeli
airstrikes in 2017 he opened the walled
off Hotel a dystopian art installation
that marked the hundred year anniversary
of British control over Palestine
the strongest work that Banksy has done
in Palestine for me is the Waldorf Hotel
in Bethlehem
this is a hotel that he calls the hotel
with the worst view in the world in that
it overlooks the Israeli wall that they
built to separate Palestine from Israel
it marks that whole Palestinian Israeli
conflict
you walk in and there is a reflection of
the part that Britain played in this
with the sort of colonial Lobby where
the piano that plays concert music
you've got Banksy pieces of art all
around the lobby and you then go from
that sort of colonial path into a museum
which goes through the whole history of
the israel-palestinian conflict and then
you've got these rooms
one of them painted by Banksy a couple
painted by others
I just think as work of art
questioning what's going on reminding
people of what's going on it's a
fabulous piece
I don't want to take sides but when you
see entire Suburban neighborhoods
reduced to Rubble with no hope in the
future what you're really looking at is
a vast outdoor recruitment center for
terrorists and we should probably
address this for all our sakes
this guy who doesn't live in this
country traveled all the way over there
and took it upon himself to make a
statement concerning a people that are
not his people an injustice that's not
necessarily his Injustice and so he
painted
with great clarity what people around
the world could imagine are the dreams
of the Palestinian people
it showed how powerful street art could
actually be if you have the proper
context and if you gave a [__]
the paintings on the Israeli separation
barrier earn Banksy a global following
and in 2006 he opened his first major
exhibition outside Britain
entitled barely legal the show was
designed along similar lines to Turf War
it was staged in the inglamorous
surroundings of a warehouse in downtown
Los Angeles
to the live painted animal this time an
elephant
and attempted to bring banksy's
alternative concept of what an art show
could be to an American audience
Banksy doesn't do exhibitions
the whole thing is an experience
I think it made a huge impact I think
that it really showed people that yeah
we can do this and there is no limits we
don't have to go to a gallery and listen
to what they say about you have a white
wall this is your space you do it now
you can say no I'm not gonna do that
I'll do my own thing
we opened it was insane we didn't know
anyone so I made everyone cue so the
only people that we'd let in ahead of
anyone else was Dennis Hopper it's the
only person I recognized and Sasha Baron
Cohen so like we had Studio bosses and
all sorts of queuing up
it was a huge success
a lot of work was bought the suggestion
was that Banksy sold three million
pounds worth of art which nowadays
doesn't seem like a huge figure but then
it was
Hollywood royalty was there it was a
sort of sensation
suddenly like everything's bathed in
blue light and Flash balls gone off oh
my gosh what's going on and then next
thing that is like Brad and Angelina
getting out of a car
now they'd not been seen in public
together for almost a year so they
turned up to the show
[Music]
suddenly there was this exhibition of an
artist no one had heard of in America
much
and it was a thing to do as a place to
go a place to be seen the place to buy
but the place to be seen and the place
to buy was not where street art had
started and the success of barely legal
brought with it a problem although
Banksy was at pains to ensure that his
shows were light years from the
traditional Gallery experience they
nevertheless remained art exhibitions
the original concept of street art
images placed anonymously and illicitly
in public spaces as free out for the
masses had nothing to do with guest
lists celebrity glamor and hype
street artist the whole thing it's
everything about site location it is a
democratic art form it's about feedback
it's all these other things that happen
I mean you know
site-specific you know this a lot
but then you have to take a bite-sized
piece of that and that goes over here
right and so then there's a change yes
can it be authentic
not in the same way
when he blew up here in the states it's
because Angelina Jolie and Brad Pitt
bought his work
that was like whoa who are they buying
and what are they collecting and we
should probably follow them because we
have no minds of our own and we only
follow celebrities
Banksy said it weirded him out
he said he couldn't sell another
painting for the next couple of years
he enjoys some of it but doesn't like
what comes with it some of the time
when I was at the airport I saw it was
either on the Banksy shows on the front
covers like over like okay her hello and
you're like wow that's you know this has
just gone nuts
[Music]
banksy's soaring profile completely
upended the established order in the art
world
together with Steve lazaridas he had
managed to create a system for art that
was entirely independent of the
galleries auction houses museums and
financiers but which they could no
longer ignore the phrase the Banksy
effect started to appear in the media
used to describe the explosion of
interest in a collection of previously
obscure underground artists
we didn't engage with the artwork
because we didn't need to
you know I don't think anyone had any
intention to wanting to be part of the
artwork you know if you think that you
know most of these guys were it was more
of a sticker to the man kind of like
attitude rather than well let's try and
get into the tape
when did the contemporary art movement
start taking notice of street art when
the press and magazines were writing
about street art more than they were
writing about Damon Hurst
and then you see Damien Hurst
collaborating with Banksy these people
aren't stupid are they
street art had to be looked at Art
critics had to look at it that it was
work that should be seen as proper art
not some Vandal just putting out a bit
of paint on a wall and it should be
considered and thought about and
shouldn't be just painted over
[Music]
thank you
by 2008 street art was a feature of
urban Landscapes across the planet and
had become the most significant art
movement of the 21st Century
[Music]
thank you
the key figures
in this movement were Shepard Ferry with
his Obey poster and his hope poster
which was a significant part in the
Obama presidential campaign
fail the Art Collective
sort of beautiful work very intense
intriguing work
Ron English who would change adverts in
an entertaining way
[Music]
Swoon one of the few women graffiti
artists who paced up her woodcuts
retina in Los Angeles who was more
graffiti but was very strong
Ben Ein
Pure Evil
Invader a French artist named after
space invader he put these small tiles
in cities across the world
people like that were making the
difference
the Banksy effect has kind of leveled
out the playing field so it's like if an
individual says I can't afford six
figures to get an actual Banksy but I
can go and support this other local
artist or this other artist who does
work that they may like that's similar
whereas 10 20 30 years ago that
conversation simply didn't happen
they actually truly believed that this
is an art movement
and the bigger you can make this
movement the better
and if you can make it a global movement
and I think he always tried to position
himself as the leader of this movement
and he's achieved that
if you think about it since the ybas
there's been no other New Movement of
our outside of what the graffitially
finger and it's probably one of the most
powerful art forms globally and has
millions and millions of followers
[Music]
foreign
the worldwide growth of street art
inevitably attracted money
big money
[Music]
the Christina Aguilera bought a Banksy
original the price of his work doubled
overnight Banksy auctions at Sotheby's
saw record bids with sales reaching many
times their upper estimates
having suddenly discovered street art
collectors now clamored to buy up as
much as they could
it was like a new [__] Gold Rush yeah
it was mental
we put a fail show on at Greek Street
and people were literally like fighting
each other to buy the paintings we did a
mick left show in Los Angeles where we
opened the doors and people literally
ran at us to come and buy buy the
paintings it was insane and you know I
think this was being whipped up by the
commercial art world as well that were
buying stuff and suddenly seeing the
returns that you can make on on Art
when people buy art today it's not
always based on what art they're drawn
to personally
at the highest echelons the real sort of
super rich
it's often because of what is
considered valuable at the time
see that's the that is
part of
the quandary
you're you're dealing with artists who
essentially give their work away
and now we come out of you're trying to
commodify pieces of it and that is a
challenge
good evening ladies and gentlemen and a
very warm welcome to Sotheby's the money
was just a byproduct no one was going
out to kind of make money we were just
trying to keep up with the people that
were buying it and flipping it so it was
like well if we charged bloody 250 quid
and they're charging 20 grand for it and
would be an idiot but I think that
ultimately it's been the thing that's at
the moment destroying the scene because
I think people are just looking at it
it's a cash cow and like you know all
the artists I ever worked with none of
them went into it for money you know Jr
Invader all these guys they went into it
because they wanted to say something
thank you
trade in prints and original canvases
intended for sale was one thing but
after people began to remove sections of
walls that had been painted in the
streets and then offer them for sale at
auction Banksy moved to try to exert
some control of the market in his work
he established Pest Control an
organization that would issue valuable
certificates of authenticity or coas
only to certain of his Works leaving the
remainder difficult to sell
what does that artist want to do with it
you know and I think if the artist wants
it to be in the gallery that's fine but
if he doesn't want to be high that's not
fine
she's dealt with this a lot right and
his stuff gets stolen and it's it's an
issue but I think he's come with a
solution right he doesn't give it a COA
so it really has no value in the high
art institutions they're still gold
diggers out there that are grabbing it
and selling it on black market and I'm
sure that'll last for a while but
eventually people are going to realize
that the end game is not worth it
pieces that we sell at bottoms are
pieces that have been purchased they
come with certificates there's a very
traceable or element of elements of a
traceable history if you like to them so
absolutely not encouraging people to
remove pieces from walls
Street pieces are straight pieces they
were created and gifted to whatever city
they're in
I think take them off the street the
morally wrong they were created for the
people to get enjoyment from not for
like one guy to go and pay someone 50
Grand to chop his wall off and then try
and sell it to a billionaire it's you
know it's wrong
nevertheless the billionaires were
interested at all showed how far
graffiti had come
in 2008 fancy held the cans Festival in
a tunnel under London's Waterloo Station
a celebration of the movement over 40 of
the world's most famous street artists
were invited to participate with an
estimated 30 000 people queuing to get
in over the May bank holiday
a year later Banksy returned home to
Stage Banksy versus Bristol Museum
his largest exhibition to date the show
was organized in partnership with
Bristol city council once enthusiastic
participants in operation Anderson and
Scourge of Bristol's graffiti artists
[Music]
Banks's fantasy that the rats the
powerless losers might one day get some
good equipment and take over had finally
been realized
for me the best of banksy's exhibitions
is Banksy versus the Bristol Museum
[Music]
this was a museum that was not getting a
great deal of support from bristolians
but then banks have started hanging his
work next to pieces and suddenly the
museum came to life
what was so outstanding to me was the
way it expanded art it brought in people
who never would have gone to that museum
who were seeing work that existed in
their city that they probably knew
nothing about
quite apart from Banksy and Lucas was
Banksy
it encouraged people to explore the
museum and look at the collection in
ways they hadn't before
[Music]
putting a sex toy in amongst the
stalactites and stalagmites
and putting a pipe with weed in amongst
the collection of Ceramics all those
things
I followed this elderly couple around
and I was struck by the fact they were
laughing
it's not very often you hear people
laugh
in art shows and museums
putting a cordon around the Gypsy
Caravan you know it made a serious point
about Travelers and the plight of
Travelers in the way that that Caravan
you know that's been in Bristol museum
for many many years has never been able
to do just changing flipping the context
[Music]
the combination of the animatronics the
interventions in the museum itself the
large-scale models like the ice cream
van and the gallery space which is
always used as the gallery space in the
museum being used as a kind of a
retrospective complete with a mock-up of
his Studio it was a really bold
statement about where he got to and to
do it in Bristol was great it was really
good for Bristol
concept of popularizing Art making it
accessible to the public by rethinking
the context started to inform much of
banksy's work which moved away from the
amusing Street stencils and into
Landmark artistic statements along the
lines of Bristol Museum
2015 he opened dismaland in Western
Superman
a seafront holiday Resort not far from
Bristol that had fallen on Hard Times
build as a amusement park dismaland was
visited by over a hundred and fifty
thousand people in little over a month
all of whom had come to see an art
exhibition reimagined as a drab
miserable and hostile amusement park
the small land was the legacy of the
museum show I think it exemplified so
much of what events is about the humor
the quality the ambition
it was also partly about the artists you
really liked he had 60 other artists
exhibiting there
what was interesting was that they came
from across the world from where Banks
had met them so you had Palestinians and
you had Israelis everyone was seeing art
they'd never seen before and there were
all kinds of things going on there the
union banners the squatting and housing
action groups which were represented
there the anarchist groups which were
represented there was a wonderful thing
I think any of us really expected him to
create something quite as magnificent as
discipline
it's as if Jeff Coons was a graffiti
writer
right and he had the resources to do
whatever the [__] he wanted to do well
that was Banksy
in his core he was still a street
graffiti guy who understood
communication to the masses high
production value for the Common Man
he's become the people's favorite artist
he is more though than just a people's
artist he's an artist who is questioning
the whole art scene which we are all
part of actually and the whole money for
art and the whole glamor for art and the
way art is being used as more than just
pictures on walls and it's that
questioning and that clever questioning
that I think is important
those questions surface persistently in
banksy's art his 2010 documentary film
exit through the gift shop explored how
art is marketed by transforming a closed
shop owner named Thierry Guetta into a
celebrated street artist from whom
people were prepared to buy millions of
dollars worth of work irrespective of
its quality
conversely a store that Banksy set up in
New York Central Park offering his work
for sixty dollars a piece failed to do
much business
without the art industry to hike them
the canvases were largely ignored a
tourist from New Zealand who purchased
two pieces of the stall was later able
to sell them for 125 000.
through it all
he's able to make us laugh at ourselves
this machine of the art world
and I think also laugh at himself
this type of performance art was as much
a commentary on what Banksy had become
as it was on the art economy
with the status as the world's most
famous artist Banksy was now an
escapably part of the over-inflated
commercialism fashion and celebrity of
the mainstream art World in a rare
interview he openly wondered whether he
had become part of the problem
his celebrity was enhanced by his much
prized anonymity a further Paradox that
reached back to the early days of
graffiti in which the writers
simultaneously sought city-wide Fame and
yet carefully hid their real names
ever since he was filmed at Tate Britain
the public had been able to associate
the name Banksy with a real figure not
just an army of rats and monkeys stamped
across British walls and yet his true
identity remained Out Of Reach
for some the hunt for Banksy became an
obsession
journalists academics and amateur
detectives scoured public records
business data and archives in Bristol
some even mapped the appearance of
Banks's pieces around the globe
correlating them with massive attack
performances and confidently announcing
that Banksy had been none other than
Robert Del Nair all along
others concluded that Banksy was a
phantom that whoever he might have once
been the name and mystery were now just
part of a well-designed publicity
campaign
perhaps this was the point about street
art a democratic Force started by kids
with nothing but marker pens and spray
cans
the world's most famous artist
could be anyone
the anonymity with banks was never a
kind of marketing thing for him I think
it was self-preservation rather than
self-promotion and I think it just
became so ingrained in his soul that I
don't think it'll ever go
[Music]
that adds a mystery and aura
you can't really divorce that from the
work I think and how it's understood
it's a great story to not know who he is
even when people know who he is they
don't want to know who he is it's a
better story not to know the theories
sort of go on and on researchers can
spend days weeks years deciding this
proves it's someone else this is part of
the game in 2018
Sotheby's auctioned girl with balloon
a work originally conceived as cheap art
for the masses
final price was one million forty two
thousand pounds a figure that had been
driven ever higher in part due to the
enduring mystery surrounding the world's
most famous artist and the persistent
question of who he might be
[Music]
the gavel came down and London's Elite
started to applaud the public finally
received their answer
[Music]
he was a vandal
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]